fléau sion bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions une seule revendication
majeure donc 48 heures de travail
hebdomadaire car il vous arrive de
travailler jusqu'à 100 heures par
semaine est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
décrire vos conditions de travail à quoi
ressemble une semaine type pour un
interne en médecine mais bonjour et
merci tout d'abord pour votre invitation
la semaine type pour un interne elle
varie bien sûr selon le mode d'exercice
dans la spécialité
mais je pense le fil conducteur est ce
qu est le plus important c'est le fait
qu'on traite de la santé des patients et
donc on a des horaires qui sont un petit
peu glissant qui est qu'à un moment on a
des impératifs de service on a une
conscience professionnelle et donc on
peut pas raisonnablement dire voilà j'ai
fait mon temps il est 18 heures
maintenant je rentre chez moi et on est
une pression terrible sur les services
avec la crise du coc vide on est
beaucoup de collègues qui eux mêmes ont
été atteintes dû s'arrêter de travailler
et donc on a été un petit peu contraint
aussi de monter en sur-régime dans un
système qui étaient déjà tendues et
aujourd'hui on le voit ça ça ne tient
plus âpres en lourd de toutes parts on a
des internats bout on a d'autres
soignants aussi qui sont à bout et
malgré no no no no appels à l'aide et un
petit peu la sonnette d'alarmé qu'on a
tiré auprès du ministère on a énormément
de mal aujourd'hui à se faire entendre
et à trouver des solutions à ce problème
justement la réglementation du temps de
travail des internes n'est pas conforme
au droit de l'union européenne vous avez
lancé un recours en novembre dernier
pour demander le respect de ses heures
travaillées et vous l'avez dit vous avez
rencontrées ces derniers temps le
ministre de la santé olivier rochus
s'est engagé à améliorer les conditions
de travail ou est ce que ça en est alors
son cynisme aucun de ma part pour ce qui
est du recours au conseil d'état
l'état est très simple nous on a fourni
nos conclusions on a fourni un certain
nombre d'éléments et le constat que que
l'on partage et qu'on déplore le
ministère de la santé a été rappelée à
l'ordre a été mis en demeure de fournir
ses conclusions il n'a pas fait à deux
reprises pour l'instant l'instruction
est en voie d'être close sans qui aucune
réponse de la part du ministère qui
semble clairement jouer la montre sur ce
dossier olivier ferrand qui s'est engagé
et a dit que c'était un problème
extrêmement grave et extrêmement
important une priorité pour lui qu'il
savait ce qu'on devait aux internes
suite à cette crise la réalité est que
son cabinet dès le lendemain ces
annonces nous a répondu et je cite si le
conseil d'état ne nous contraint pas à
le faire nous ne découvrons pas le temps
de travail des internes en médecine à
l'hôpital
voilà c'est aujourd'hui l'état du
dossier
et à quoi est-ce que vous êtes tribus et
cette surcharge de travail au qu'ovide à
la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement bien ce que ses antérieurs
à la crise s qui a un côté systémique
que vous dénoncez alors il ya un côté
systémique un problème qui est bien
antérieure à la crise qui a été aggravée
ou en tout cas il ya des faiblesses qui
ont été mis en lumière
voilà la cause de la pression
supplémentaire qui a été mise sur
l'hôpital aujourd'hui on n'attend pas
une réponse miraculeuse et une réponse
instantanée mais plus un engagement
c'est un problème qui a évolué sur les
30 ou 40 dernières années à cause d'un
certain nombre de politiques de gestion
notamment de l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui on sait bien que le problème
peut pas être résolu instantanément et
on n'appelle pas d'ailleurs un respect
strict du temps de travail si
aujourd'hui on limité à 48 heures le
temps trail des internes le jeudi soir
il y aurait plus personne dans les
hôpitaux et ce serait absolument
intenable donc on appelle à une prise de
conscience et aller vers une évolution
vers une adaptation pour que ce soit
insupportable pour tout le monde et donc
que les patients puissent être soignés
correctement on entend bien votre
messager et vos revendications pourtant
il ya quand même une figure de la santé
19 milliards d'euros qui ont été mis sur
la table par l'exécutif c'est pas
suffisant c'est beaucoup d'argent quand
même c'est beaucoup d'argent mais en
fait c'est un problème qui est qui est
bien plus profond que ça et c'est pas
une question en fait tant de
d'émoluments une rémunération c'est ce
que j'ai répondu de manière un peu
simpliste à d'autres journalistes qui me
l'avait demandé mais pour les internes
qui se sont ôtés la vie ils se sont ôtés
la vie non pas parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas payés à la fin du mois mais très
bien parce qu' il ne pouvait plus
supporter la charge de travail donc une
grève de
jours pour le moment est ce qu elle
pourrait être prolongée si oui combien
de temps jusqu'à quand et quelle future
action est ce que vous envisagez pour
pouvoir vous faire entendre
la grève pourrait être prolongé le
préavis qu'on a déposé le permet
simplement c'est un symbole c'est deux
jours de grève 48 heures pour 48 heures
de travail hebdomadaire à l'hôpital
c'est ce qu'on réclame aujourd'hui on
espère pouvoir être reçus par le
ministère de la santé
et on ne souhaite pas prolonger
indéfiniment la grève et mettre en
difficulté les services puisque avant
tout quand même on doit être présent
pour soigner nos patients on ne peut pas
se permettre de dépouiller l'hôpital
public de ces soignants
est ce que cette grève va être suivie
est ce que vous avez déjà des premiers
chiffres et quant à la participation de
la mobilisation cet après midi à paris
qu'est ce que vous envisagez qu'est ce
que vous espérez alors on espère
toujours le plus on sait
qu'historiquement c'est difficile de
mobiliser les médecins ce que je
déplorais à défaut d'avoir les chiffres
pour l'instant c'est on nous a remonté
énormément de cas où la mobilisation est
problématique avec des chefs de service
qui ont réquisitionné de manière abusive
les internes au mépris du droit de grève
qui ont empêché un certain nombre d'
interne de faire grève ou beaucoup qui
nous ont répondu tout simplement je ne
peux pas je n'ai pas le temps je ne peux
pas m'absenter de mon service pour faire
grève et paradoxalement on travaille
trop pour avoir le temps de faire grève
pour ses conditions de travail
il y a un an et demi les soignants était
applaudi par les français lors du
premier confinement qu elle ressentit
vous avez de la part de la population
française vous sentez soutenu dans vos
revendications
bien sûr on sent une grande
bienveillance surtout à la sortie de
cette crise de la part de la population
aujourd'hui le message que moi
j'aimerais vraiment pas cessé de dire
cette revendication c'est nous qui l'
important mais les premières personnes
qui sont impactés après les internes ce
sont nos patients puisqu'un interne qui
a travaillé 96 heures par semaine
forcément ne peut pas bien prendre en
charge un de ses patients et c'est faire
courir des risques inutiles
hoarau à la population et c'est vraiment
pour ça qu'on les appelle à se mobiliser
avec nous sur ce sujet qui est un enjeu
de qualité des soins à l'hôpital public
merci les aussillon pour votre message
je rappelle que vous êtes premier
vice-président de l'intersyndicat
national des internes